good day everyone and welcome i'm jack van horn
from the university of virginia please allow
me to welcome you to our 2021 foundations
of biomedical data science seminar series
working previously with colleagues through
the nih's big data to knowledge program we
began this seminar several years ago with the goal
providing a foundational resource for the theory
practice and applications of data science and
biomedical research now based at the university
of virginia we are now continuing this seminar
series with a focus on the data science and its
particular applications in thematic biomedical
topic areas the theme for this year is the brain
and the data science necessary to process analyze
model integrate and interpret brain form function
and connectivity across scales in health and in
disease the variety and richness excuse me the
variety and richness and scale of neurobiological
data types increasingly necessitates novel data
science methods advancing uh data processing
data mining statistical analysis and synthesis
uh and visualization are all needed to make
this make progress in the neurosciences to
characterize complete um and come up with uh more
comprehensive neurobiological systems um these are
be important for the identifying most efficacious
treatments for development neuropsychological and
neuropsychiatric diseases as well as syndromes
which affect the brain as we age over the coming
weeks we'll present a blend of lectures on the
basics of data science brain science and their
intersection these videos are being streamed live
via youtube are also being recorded and will take
their place in a corpus of foundational video
content concerning data science applications
in biomedical sciences please share the
youtube channel link with your colleagues
your students and other interested stakeholders in
beginning this year's seminar series i'm pleased
to welcome professor don brown from the school
of data science at the university of virginia
who will present his appropriately entitled
lecture how to do data science donald brown
is the founding director of the data science
institute at the university of virginia the
co-director of the integrated translational
health research institute of virginia i thrive
and the quantitative foundation distinguished
professor and professor of data science
here at the university of virginia which is
the first such school of its kind in the united
states focused on the subject of data science dr
brown is a fellow of the ieee and recipient of
the ieee joseph wall career achievement award for
his work in systems engineering and data fusion
he conducts research in predictive technology
data integration machine learning and simulation
operative optimization with applications to health
science security and to safety our innovation lab
participants should be able to submit questions
for dr brown via their zoom chat feature i
will synthesize these and present them to dr brown
for discussion during the last 10 minutes or so of
the seminar with that welcome don we are very
much looking forward to your lecture well thank
you very much jack i appreciate that very nice
introduction so i'm going to jump right into it as
to how to do data science and i'm going to start
with telling you a little bit about the school of
data science at the university of virginia because
that gives a background to what we're going to be
talking about we call it a school without walls
and a comprehensive university and by that we
mean that we are we reach out we're not uh we're
not like a lot of data science programs that come
out of a single department uh for instance
a statistics or computer science department
nor are we one that come out of the joining
of two departments or within a single school
we are in fact a school that uh exists on its
own and it reaches out to all schools at the
university and we have another 11 schools at
uva that we reach out to and in doing so we
try and leverage the research and scholarship
of those other schools that we have at uva
in order to uh to create a data science a
set of data science programs and to conduct
research in data science we've been advised by
business government and academic partners and
that's what's given us a a sense of what data
science should be in the world that expands
these areas business government and academic
uh institutions um we also coordinate a lot of
all of the teaching uh in data science across
these disciplines across programs throughout
the university and we created new educational
programs particularly in the master's program but
we now have a phd program that's uh that's under
review and we have a an undergraduate program
that we'll be rolling out soon as well as well as
an undergraduate minor that is already in place
we enhance we also enhance the hardware and
software infrastructure that supports data science
okay so um let's start out with a little question
about what is data science and it started out with
the idea of what is big data and when there was
this great joke that big data is like teenage sex
everyone talks about it nobody really knows how
to do it everyone thinks everyone else is doing it
so everyone claims they are doing it and uh
this is this is sort of the underlying joke
behind the area but uh that dan nearly had it's a
very very nice little uh way to uh to think about
what we're about in a lot of institutions
uh but to get more serious uh what is data
science well actually data science has been a
field our topic of discussion in academia and
business and in government for a long time
well at least since the 1960s it's been
definitely in papers that people have talked about
data science in 1998 wu gave a very interesting
talk in michigan where he said that really
data science and statistics but since then
and frankly even then most people didn't
believe that and in fact they've felt that it's
it's quite different it's aryan in and of itself
but what is that area in and of itself well
let's take a look at some some some things that
others have written about what data science is
a concept to unify statistics data analysis
machine learning domain knowledge related
methods in order to understand and analyze actual
phenomena and this is what hayashi said also in 98
and then you've got this one from leak the key
word is data science not data it is science data
science is only useful when the data are used
to answer a question um and then we have dar
who wrote that data science is a study of the
generalizable extraction of knowledge from data
and lowe who said data science is a
multi-disciplinary blend of data inference
algorithm development and technology in order to
solve analytically complex problems now i could
give you more and more of these things but i guess
the point i'd like to make is that there are two
central concepts that come out of just reading all
but wu's initial comment there are two things that
sort of run through all of these definitions and
as i say there are many more i could give you that
these two concepts also appear in i think for a
moment and see if you can uh and see what those
two concepts are and if you if you have them
write them in the chat and i'll uh i'll try and
take them as uh his input to this but think about
what uh what those two areas are and i guess it
as you're thinking about it notice that
uh we haven't a lot of them this unifying
of multiple areas okay blend of data inference
algorithm development technology so this idea of
integration of fields uh interdisciplinarity runs
along a lot of the ideas of what data science is
and the other thing that runs into
it a lot of them is this idea of
analyzing actual phenomena answer a question
okay solve an analytically complex problem
these are the two things that we're going to
focus on because those that we consider to be at
the heart of what data science is so let's take
the first one data science combines disciplines
um there are a lot of sort of these venn
diagrams of data science that that try
and capture this idea the data science is an
interdisciplinary activity i'm giving you one of
the very simplest of these and they're a lot that
are very complicated some that are quite funny
but they're the basic ideas is that data science
seems to be about bringing together a number of
areas in order to answer a question and there's
there's another version of it we like to say data
science as a team sport so you can think
about all these different areas all these
interdisciplinary areas coming together around the
idea of trying to solve a data science question
and that's that's at the heart of a lot of what
we think about in data science is this notion of
bringing together these different fields in order
to solve the problem and the other aspect as i say
is the solving of a problem how do we how do we
we need to solve a problem so it's you know again
one version of it is it's extracting knowledge in
order to do this okay in order to solve a problem
but fundamentally then if you once you understand
okay it's great it's uh this interdisciplinary
approach and it's focused on a particular problem
there's this is a very application oriented field
the question then is how do you do it how
do you go about doing this um and i i love
this quote from tooky because it really gets it
uh the frustration you can he pointed out the
combination of some data and an aching desire
for an answer does not ensure that a reasonable
answer can be extracted from a given body of data
so just because you know you've got the data and
boy you really want to solve the problem
and you've got all these different fields
doesn't necessarily mean you're going to get an
answer and you're going to get the answer that
you're looking for in particular but you're that
you're going to be able to solve it you've got to
have something else and then something else is
you need to have an approach you need to have a
structured way to go about the problem in order
to get an answer and that's what we're going to
talk about throughout this talk is how do we go
about doing that well one of the earliest ways
that people uh presented for doing data science
was what was called the cross industry process
for data mining or chris dm and it represents this
process flow it says you start out with some sort
of a business because this was a business oriented
uh group that came up with this idea they were
they were looking at as a business understanding
but you can think about this in general you could
think about this is the understanding the health
sciences application that you're working on data
understanding you're trying to understand what the
data have in it then you do the preparation the
wrangling all that kind of stuff then you do the
analytics or the modeling the evaluation of your
results and then you communicate your results
through deployment and this method really does
describe a lot of what it is that we're about when
we think about data science but we were somewhat
dissatisfied with it because it implies a process
flow that doesn't really get it the way that a lot
of us work on data science problems and one of
the key insights came from a colleague of mine
when we were we were looking and we looked at
probably uh 15 or 20 of these things and then
i'll give him credit he noticed the idea that you
can actually fold them one on top of the other so
in fact you could bring this data understanding
a business understanding you can look at this as
one area you could look at data understanding and
deployment you could fold them back on each other
data preparation as well bottom line is
is that we we came up with a different
way to think about it that we think really
captures more about what data science is about
and we call this the four plus one model and
the four plus one model is the four major areas
in these four areas are value design analytics
and systems these are the the four areas that we
consider to be the critical parts of data science
and operation and at the center of it is this
notion that i said is critical in data science
you're solving a problem and we call that practice
uh you're solving a problem for some real
application you're trying to answer a question
and that's the bull's eye and this in this notion
that's the plus one that's where we're looking
it's it's in the middle because it it's the key
focus for all areas that we're working on the
four areas represent the four key aspects of data
science and then the the center point represents
uh what we we really want to keep in mind at all
points so it intersects with everything that we're
trying to solve a problem for some organization
uh in the real world now i'm going to talk about
those intersection points and you can see you've
got concrete human abstract i'm going to postpone
talking about those for a little bit and and go
into some of the other the specific the four areas
here um so that we have a better definition
and the first one we think about is value
and what value does is it represents this
combination of both ethics and business
planning it's bringing together and again you can
replace business with organizational planning or
organizational understanding what is it that we're
we're after what what is the what is the problem
that we're having to deal with and how does that
relate to the organization how does it provide
value to that organization how is it moving that
organization forward in some way and at the same
time what are the ethics what are the what
are the values as they relate to the ethical
concerns around the problem that you're dealing
with and there typically are those and in every
problem we deal with we come up with these kind
of issues and we need to we need to deal with
them up front and center in in doing data science
and they're the these these other points there's
policy making organizational motivation all
these things are part of this value component
a key part of the value step
if you will of the value
aspect of data science is the formation
of what we call a value proposition
where we describe specifically what value this
or values this particular work is going to bring
to the world into the organization for whom it's
done there the one nice thing about this four
plus one model is that we we expose tensions
and tensions are good tensions tell us that
these are the values or these are the sorry the
trade-offs that we've got when we're working in
this space because you can't work in in a space
like data science without experiencing trade-offs
they're always going to be trade-offs in the way
that you perform this work if you if you expose
them and make them explicit then you can deal with
them in a much more effective way and clearly we
have these tensions here we have enterprise versus
ethical values another way private interest versus
public good the organization has issues it has
or it has values it has things that it wants to
accomplish but at the same time we have to think
about the larger values that we have to society
or the values that we have to individuals that
for whom we're working with in order to accomplish
the data science project we have to think about
these larger societal values whenever we we do a
data science project as well as the organizational
values for the organization that we're working for
okay design the next component of this four plus
one model design is the human centered part of
this this is where we really think about the
human being interacting with the with the data
science piece this is where you really look at
what the data is as a data science as a data
scientist or data analyst you're trying to
understand the data you're the human trying
to understand what it is that you're dealing with
but it also deals with your your customers your
stakeholders everybody that you're interacting
with the design component is all about this human
interaction with the uh with the data with
the technologies uh where the products of the
technologies where the products of the data
science work all of that is what's involved
the little picture that i'm showing you is this
typical way that we think about design is it's
it's actually giving us ways to visualize a lot
of i mean visualization is a key part of design
how do we visualize the data how do we visualize
the structures that we're dealing with and
as a data scientist we want to understand
the data and visualization is one very
powerful way to do it but as consumers of data
science projects our customers our clients our
sponsors they want a visual visualization
is a good way to see what it is that you've
accomplished and in the examples i'm going to give
in this talk i'll try to describe some of those
some key activities then in this area a
representation in communication through
database design the curation of data as i say
the visualization of complex data okay the
display and visualization and visualization of the
analytical results the showing of those results
tables uh we use a lot but we also use
visualizations uh tensions discovery
versus product uh this is uh this is a major
tension using user facing versus analyst facing
another tension is it is it something that the
analyst understands and gets in but the user has
no clue the sponsor the the clients they've got
no clue what you're talking about these kind of
tensions exist within the design component and uh
and they're things that we again we're aware of
once we make them explicit and we're aware of
them we can we can take actions and deal with it
okay the systems framework is uh is part of the uh
the data science i i i say this that the the two
the first two value i think people think about
but they they don't necessarily think about it
the way that we've we've structured in terms
of this uh both the value of the organization
and the value to society and the value to
the individuals that we're working with
and design frankly a lot of people don't
really call out as a separate and equal
component to these other areas the next two this
one in particular systems in the analytics piece
people think of all the time when they think of
data science these are the ones that most people
frankly firmly associate with data science the
systems area is the area where we think about
the computation this is the infrastructure that
provides the support for working with the data
that we're we're working the data that we need
to solve our problems it includes not only the
the structure the underlying hardware but it
includes the software as well in particular
the pipelines to move the data to where they need
to be moved in order to get the job done for us
we think of it as computational science and
technology necessarily opposed to computer science
and the key activities here are really developing
really this this infrastructure this performance
infrastructure that can that can accomplish
what we need to do and we think about cloud
resources this is the the name of the game
today but it involves a lot of other things
as well and some of those are mentioned
here including the networks uh the the
resilient uh pieces of this of the network and
the underlying infrastructure and as i said
also the software involved in accomplishing
this the tensions here we have development
versus production because a lot of times there's
tremendous pressure to get production systems out
as opposed to really spending the time that's
needed in order to build the the resiliency
that we need uh and maintainability in these
systems volume versus speed another major uh uh
area of tension extensible versus
media these are the kind of tensions
again explicitly making everybody aware that
we've got these tensions as we go through it
analytics when people think of data science
they add they completely associate analytics
with data science and it is an absolute it is
a very key element this is one of the major
uh the two major things that i think have made
data science what it is frankly are the the
this one and the one that i just talked about we
now have the hardware systems that allow us to
accomplish tasks that we were frankly impossible
before and we have the analytical methods we
we've produced the methodologies today that can
actually go after incredibly difficult problems
so these two together have really
elevated data science to a major field
and made us what we are in terms of the things
that we can accomplish with uh with the field
so i'm spend a moment here on analytics these are
the mathematical machine learning kinds of things
that we think about when we think about data
science and it involves all these things there
i mean i can there's a long list and i've only
listed a few here optimization signal processing
neural networks and i've got a picture of a deep
learning network on the right these are the kinds
of things that you think of when you think about
the analytics but it incorporates all aspects of
this we are bringing together the the broad swath
of analytical capabilities that have been built up
and continue to be built i mean it's an ongoing
area it's wonderful to watch and wonderful to
be part of to watch uh what's happening in
this area and the tremendous methodologies
uh ex wonderful methodologies that are being
produced on almost a daily basis key activities
here is obviously converting this is where the you
know the rubber meets the road taking the data and
turning it into something that's useful turning
it into the answers to the questions that we we've
got that we've posed this is where it actually
gets done is in this analytical part of the uh
data science structure that we've described the
four plus one model so this is where we're really
meeting the challenge that we've got the tensions
here there are many of them again i'm mentioning
just a few one of the big ones that people talk
about a lot is causality versus correlation
and whether we need causality or whether we can
be satisfied with correlation is correlation
sufficient for us do we really need to drive
to causality do we need to understand that
inference versus prediction another one that's
spun out um prediction has been the the news
the new major uh evaluation methodology that we
see in data science but we continue to rely on
inferential methods observation versus experiments
uh feature selection versus feature engineering
how do we how do we pick and understand the
contributors the predictive variables that are
contributing to the answers that we're seeing and
accuracy versus interpretability a lot of problems
we can produce incredibly accurate
results but we've got no clue we've
done it through black boxes that we don't
understand and we can't explain very well
so these are all issues these are tensions
that we have in the analytics area
okay and and the last and as i say the bull's
bullseye in this whole process is practice this
is where the problem is and practice is what
brings everybody together it makes it the team
signs okay this is characterized by everybody
working together uh you know you've got domain
experts people really really understand
at a deep level what the problem domain is
and they can help when working with the people
who are deep into the data science methodology
understand how to go after the particular
problem that you're you're uh that you're
going for um and so you you you work together in
order to produce uh these kind of the solutions
that are actually going to be uh true solutions
and not just theoretical solutions or solutions
that get written up in a paper and never read
or you know not used but actually translational
solutions solutions that make a difference
and actually help an organization advance okay
key activities contact with domain knowledge and
real world problems this is uh this it's all about
actually digging in and understanding uh what it
is that you you've got in the area that you're
you're working what you've got at the level of
knowledge and what you've got at the level of
data and what you've got at the level of
people who understand the characteristics of
those tensions goals versus resources
uh this is this tension just exists in
every problem-solving domain uh you've gotta
you've got a lot of ambition but do you have
the resources to go after it and can you
bring the kind of teams together with the
resources the teams need in order to solve these
problems uh integration versus decomposition
uh typically you've got you know analytics versus
uh you know synthesis and and this is always these
kinds of things play out in many real problems
and data of science versus practical understanding
when i i teach data science i try and get my
data science students to understand that when
they work in an area they can't expect that
the their subject matter experts in that area
are going to do everything they've got to learn
that domain they've got to get in and understand
it well enough that they can communicate in a
professional way with their uh um with their
data with their colleagues who are steeped in
that domain and they've got to understand it
so that they're asking the kind of questions and
working with them in a way that's effective and
this this is a tension that exists in almost every
team that goes after these data science problems
okay so let me uh let me summarize a little
bit about this four plus one model and say
with a couple of key points here first one
is that uh this is a not unlike these process
models that people have thought of and in terms
of doing data science this four plus one model
is not a linear model but we typically start with
value okay so it isn't like you go from value to
design analytics to systems it's that we don't
think about it that way but we do we do say that
you start with value there's virtually we i can't
think of any problem but i'm i'm not going to say
never because it's possible that you can think
of a problem that doesn't start with value but
every problem that i've worked in starts with
value that value component is absolutely key
you want to understand the problem from the
perspective of the organization what is it that
they want to accomplish what are their goals what
are their objectives but also what are the ethical
issues what are the societal issues and impact
upon those goals and objectives and how do they
influence the way that you're going to conduct
data science and the ways you think about it
okay another point is the way that we try to
draw this is visually to give you the sense
that practice intersects with everything okay
it's it's absolutely important that whatever you
do you're always thinking about the problem it's
not it isn't again the problem we have with those
process models is frankly they give the impression
that you do that what we're calling the value step
the value proposition kind of piece you do that
you get it done and then you forget about it and
move on to the next piece uh that's not the way
it's done here this this is an intersection with
practice and this intersection with practice
means that you have to think about that that
what you discover in that value component is it
as it impacts on the question you have in the
practical area carries through in everything you
do and your impact and you're constantly working
with people who are experts in the domain
to understand the kind to understand the
data science piece as you go through it and if
you happen to be an expert in this in whatever
domain which i think most of you probably are
you then are actually you're intersecting at
the value design and analytics and systems area
as well you're you're kind of coming from the
middle out and you're saying okay i'm going to
do these pieces and that's great and that's the
kind of thing we want you to think about is
that that practice intersects with everything
the emphasis is not always the same here you
could some problems are going to emphasize
analytics more some problems are going
to emphasize design there's some problems
frankly they don't care about analytics very
much they care about the visualizations they
care about the communications aspects which
means they're very very focused on design
and so and that's fine uh it isn't that each one
of these things has to get equal emphasis in every
problem they're going to be problem dependent um
so don't don't think that there's this suggests
just i mean again we draw it this way to emphasize
that we consider them all equal parts and doing
data science but they they're not necessarily
all equal in doing a data science problem
okay the meaning of the boundaries uh these things
all have uh interesting boundaries and frankly i
could talk and talk about this uh four plus one
model and all the interesting uh uh pieces of it
but i'm just gonna point out and i'd like you to
think about it that when you look for instance at
the intersection between or at the boundary i'll
say between value and design that's it's a human
boundary because both of them are very concerned
about talking to people there the interaction is
with people more than it is with i'd say uh uh
analytics or with uh with machines or things uh
that are uh that are solid in the world this is
about people talking to people is what that that
intersection is about both of those areas are very
much concerned about this this human interactions
that that's key to data science on the other
hand if you look at the opposite side systems and
analytics they're intersecting with the machine
they're very much focused on how what's the
hardware and the software that's on there and that
hardware going to do for me they're very focused
on looking at the capabilities of those machines
in there and how they're going to accomplish their
tasks again i'm using a machine but machine i
mean that as well in the software parts it's on
those machines um the boundary between uh systems
and value is concrete it's this is uh you want to
make it very very precise and understandable
and it's uh and it's concrete in the sense of
language and uh in communication between them uh
in terms of design and analytics it's abstract
we we write a lot of it is mathematical a
lot of it is pictures and graphs or displays
these kinds of things exist between these areas
and and so these boundaries make a you know they
provide a little bit of meaning of where these
these four areas overlap with each other and
enhance share commonness between their activities
okay one thing that the four plus one model does
is it provides a way as all process models do but
the four plus one again is not strictly a process
model but it does provide what process models do
which is that notion of completeness and coverage
have you done what you need to do in order
to get the data science question answered and
that's what this kind of approach does for you it
allows you to make sure that you've you've really
done due diligence there okay i'm going to turn
now to a couple of examples i've talked at the
high level of what the what the four plus
one model is and how to do data science with
and i'm going to give you a couple of examples
now as to how this is done i don't work in uh
in neuroscience or in the science of brain but i
i have a several health science examples that i've
worked on and i'm going to describe those as uh
as examples of this one of them is environmental
enteropathy which has to do with children and
the other one is adverse surgical outcomes
okay environmental enteropathy environmental
anteropathy is a relatively newly classified
disease it's only been classified in the last
four years it's a subclinical inflammation
inflammatory disease of the of the intestine
and if you look at the right you can see this uh
this notion of what's happening here uh you can
see that uh that normally we have a on the left we
have a healthy uh representation where we've got
lots of surface area that basically can absorb uh
the nutrients that are that are coming through and
on the right we have uh a non-healthy situation
where we have decreased electrolyte absorption
we have decreased absorption generally uh so
this kind of uh the villi on the left are uh
are are healthy they're able and this this is
a this very very nice design that we have which
allows us in a very small space to have a very
very large surface area for this absorption and
unfortunately in the right hand side because of
a number of environmental conditions it becomes
diseased and unable to absorb so this kind of
condition is associated with malabsorption
linear faltering and stunting children with it
are stunted impaired cognitive development reduced
responsiveness to nutritional intervention as well
so nutritional intervention of course is the
first uh point that we take and these children
frequently don't respond well or at all to it
and also they don't respond to uh immunogenic
in vaccination oral vaccination as well
okay what's the value the value piece of
this is uh is really very clear half the
global deaths uh in children under five years
are attributable to under nutrition and uh
and thus the study of this is is of tremendous
value uh it's a worldwide value uh to to really
understand what's happening here not only to
the individual countries but also the world
we need to understand we need to treat
this and you can see that it is a
something that's not a focus just in one area but
it's focused in a number of areas throughout the
world it's an important concern the ethical
issues here clearly clearly is in all health
issues we need to think about the privacy and
protection of the patients that we're dealing with
and we also need to think about in this particular
case research collaborations that are truly
collaborations and that are not uh dominated uh
you know as has happened unfortunately where um
some countries uh you know say our country comes
in and and tries to say this is the way you should
do things this is a collaborative effort it's a
collaborative effort with the countries in which
we're we're working in order to accomplish these
tasks and these kinds of collaborative efforts
are incredibly important in order to make these
uh these solutions lasting and effective you can
do all the great data analysis you want but
if you don't create the kind of collaborative
infrastructure at the research level and at the
uh at the translational level for getting these
these solutions implemented then it's all for not
so it's incredibly important for us to have these
collaborations uh and and to understand uh how
to create those collaborations at the beginning
okay design we've got in this particular case
we had a hundred and this is one example we've
got a lot of these things but uh give one
example here we had 108 d identified biopsies
and they came from a number of different diseases
celiac environmental enteropathy and and normals
okay or controls and the way that we do this is
that we cut up the image as it's shown and we
we do this in order that we can deal with it with
the fact that it's a very high resolution image
okay um yeah you can see see like in normal
biopsies where photographs ee biopsies were
digitized slides data were augmented by a factor
of 30 via rotation horizontal and vertical and i
show that on the bottom there so you can see we
can rotate these things uh in order to get in
order to increase the number of data elements that
we have to work with in our models uh the patches
then are from wholesaling images so we're going to
we're going to cut it up we're going to grid this
thing and we're going to look at patches from
the whole slide image because we can't our our
analytics can't deal with the with the whole slide
but we can deal with patches from the whole slide
i'm going to mention this color balancing in a
minute but that's a result of the staining and
it's it's a big deal for us in order to uh to work
on this problem okay um so the pre-processing as
i say we first we grid the image uh and after
doing that uh we create these patches uh and
and some of those patches are absolutely worthless
because they're taking pictures of nothing or very
very almost nothing and so we run that through a
process in this case it's uh it's what's called
an auto encoder in order to do a clustering and
find the areas in the uh the patches that are
actually worth uh using for our modeling approach
uh and this is a key part of this design piece is
understanding that i mentioned the staining uh
hemotoxical aminos and staining uh h e staining
uh this produces different colors based upon the
characteristics of the uh the underlying tissue
and uh but unfortunately those those
colors also depend on local conditions
uh in the labs and that creates a bias uh in our
particular case for example we had the only the
the normal we got from a number of places
including uh the united states but we have
no uh environmental enteropathy cases from the
united states so there's a natural bias that
can cry that can occur because uh what we're what
what we're doing when we're doing the modeling is
just finding a color difference represented
by the staining and not any real difference
that exists in the underlying tissue and that's
a problem so we need to deal with that as part of
design and this is what's called color balancing
it seems to convert all these images to the same
normalized color space so that we don't have
any bias as a result of that the analytics
that we use we use convolutional neural nets
and i've got a picture there i'm not going
to go into the details this isn't the talk to
go in the details of convolutional neural nets
but uh we that's what that that's what we do
these are the latest techniques for for going
after these kind of images these are what's called
a deep learning architecture uh and we can employ
it for this hierarchical image classification
problem uh these these layers are called feature
maps we can stack them together we can do all
sorts of cool things in order to go after this
and the output then is actually a probability
of classification into one of these disease
categories from the system standpoint i'll just
say that we create pipelines to process the data
we we use the cluster systems or clusters of
computers we also use graphical processing
units or gpus these are the latest or these are
things that have been around for a while for
for really the gaming industry but they
they're exploited by us because they
they work very well on these uh for these deep
learning problems and they allow us to really find
uh where the the knee of the curve is when we're
trying to calibrate our models so we're building
an infrastructure systems infrastructure that
has those capabilities is very important to us
okay at the other end when we get the results we
have a design piece as well we have to show people
the results and and the first table here shows
the results that we get when we when we train on
one color balancing approach and test on that
same color balancing approach and you can see
that we get very good results we're getting
uh we're getting good classifications for
environmental enteropathy pretty good for normal
and uh doing well as well for celiac disease
and and we do it as well when we change the color
balancing in the test set you can see that we uh
the the approach remains robust to these kinds
of things uh and that's what we're trying to
show is the the accuracy here and the important
thing is is that we're getting better accuracy
than pathologists with environmental enteropathy
because it is a new disease not well understood
and we're getting a it's robust uh to this color
balancing problem that we mentioned with the h e
staining and that's the kind of result that
we like to see in these in these approaches
okay uh i'm going to then shift to another example
problem to show you the this uh four plus one
model and this one is adverse surgical outcomes
and the the outcome we're going to look at is aki
the sudden inability of the kidney to clean the
blood of toxins and you can see that it occurs in
the united states with not a not an insignificant
amount of cases 25 000 per year um and i don't
have a date there but i think that was uh 16 is
when that last was recorded um okay 20 24 to 48
hours to diagnose using current methods you've
got to you've got to say that this is a this is
a potential problem really fast uh the mortality
rate increases uh as a result requiring a hospital
five times during hospitalization so it's got to
be diagnosed quickly um current predictive model
for uh for this uh so what's the value value is
is that the current predictive model really is
not very good it comes out of this model from the
society for thoracic uh surgeons used only it uses
only preoperative data it fails uh to accurately
identify at risk patients and i'm going to show
you that in a little bit here with sufficient time
to prevent injury the goal then the value here is
then to provide more accurate prediction of aki
for earlier intervention so what you want is you
really want to do a number of things you want to
say something about creatine change you want to
say something about rifle categories which is no
classification risk injury failure or loss these
are the ways that it's currently thought about in
that in that current model and the ethics of this
are around the need again to protect uh personal
information and the you know this is a classic
problem we have in the health area that we may
have we may have something that is misrepresenting
the underlying population in many ways we may not
our patient population may not be representing the
general population we we we're dealing with
we may uh build models that are basically uh
only effective for certain classes of patients and
we we need to think about this we need to think
about the stratification of our patient population
as we go into these okay the systems area
we we've got a variety of machines that we can
use on it we've got large clusters again we've
got gpus we need to do this rapidly and provide
the results in the operating room if possible
there are there are three major areas that
we were looking at creatine change rifle
categories no class which says uh hey look do
something now or don't don't worry it's okay
and the approaches that we we're using again
there's a laundry list of techniques that were
that we that we applied to these kind of problems
and they're listed on the right these are
analytical solutions that come out of this
whole bag of tricks in the analysis area
that have been built up in the last 20 uh or
so plus years to uh to go after these sorts
of problems and all of them were applied
here in order to try and understand uh
what it is that we were dealing with and could
we in fact solve these different problems
the design the sadly we only had 5 000 surgeries
in this in the data set that we could work with
but even more sadly if you look at uh
missing data extreme values and mixed
mismatches between data sets we ended up with
only 335 that could be used for the analysis
so it's this is a a problem that we find all the
time again in the health area that we need to work
with and and we also have imbalance uh creatinine
change is just showing you a little bit of that
imbalance that it's it's it's in balance in
certain ways that that allows us not to be able to
to apply these models as effectively without doing
other things we need to we need to reach into a
bag of tricks and understand how to go at it the
design there's a lot of this in the in the design
area here that i clearly this is just to tell
you that uh in order to do this problem a lot of
work was spent in in order to get the data to the
point that we can actually use it very effectively
i'm going to point out only one piece here in
the middle and that's that in order to deal
with this this missing data and characteristics
we use simulations okay we simulated uh patient
characteristics in order to create a more
balanced training set that we can actually use
for our results and that's a key part of a lot of
again health problems you have to think cleverly
about how you can you can build uh data that can
be used for uh for doing the analytics and the
design places where a lot of that is where that
work gets done in order to uh to provide you with
the data that you need for the analytics this is
just to show you i told you that that sts baseline
the society of thoracic surgeons baseline
is not very good and this kind of shows you
that result if you look here you see
that their model basically predicts
renal failure for patients uh whoops
sorry i gotta try and use my mouse
without flipping through these screens okay
so if you look they're predicting people
that had no credit and change okay or very little
creatinine change this is what they're predicting
as a result and all the people that were most
affected okay all of them were not predicted
okay so this model is totally
ineffective in doing what it needs to do
which again is back to that value of what uh
what we're about in contrast you can see that the
results that were built here do a pretty decent
job of doing it they're predicting pretty well
uh the predicted results okay and the observed
results they're missing some however okay they're
missing some down here but they're doing pretty
well at predicting across again a small data
set but they're predicting much better than
you're getting out of the current system
and that's what we're after you can look at the
rifle categories as well and see once again the
predictions here are quite good compared to what
they are with the current system they're still
not they're still not great in the sense that
they're doing perfectly but they're doing much
better and in fact they're tending to overpredict
with only a couple cases of underpredicting
with fewer cases of underpredicting which is again
showing improvements on this on this the same
thing can be done with a binary classification
predicting injury and failure um we're seeing
this again improved performance again not
perfect performance but improved performance
with these results we also can find the
significant predictor so we can give the
clinicians a sense of where to look in order
to understand again these are models that we
that are not black boxes that we can go in and
we can look at characteristics that can help them
understand and communicate with them again this
is at the design level communicating with them
what it is that they need to look at clinically
in order to uh to make these make these decisions
about possible uh adverse surgical outcomes
okay i'm going to summarize then and say
data science as we've seen it integrates
disciplines and technologies to solve problems and
extract knowledge from data so it's it's all about
this interdisciplinary integrative approach which
is after real problems real pro important problems
the four plus one model as i said i think we've
we've put together a way to think about
data science that helps guide us and when
we're doing data science if we think about these
four areas as we go into a data science problem
always centered on practice what the problem is
then we've got a good framework for approaching uh
solving true data science problems okay i
think i've got 10 minutes left as was asked
so um i guess i'd like to turn it back over
jack i can see the questions or you can
do what you want what would you how would you like
to do it jack don firstly thank you so much for uh
that's a great overview of data science and
why we want to practice this um we do have
a couple of questions that are are out there let
me just before we begin those those are a little
more technical let me uh just ask you a couple
more broader based questions before we begin
um i sort of got i think i know the answer
to this but i wanted to get your impressions
about this is data science itself an insular
discipline that is is you know can one do data
science for the sake of data science or is
it inherently a multi-disciplinary effort
uh data science is inherently a multi-disciplinary
effort uh you you really i mean in our world in
the in the world that we're dealing with
now where data science is so important
it has to be multi-disciplinary it has to bring
all these characteristics that we've talked about
here uh you can't be i mean don't get me wrong
they're people who can be very specialized and
and that's where a lot of quote data
scientists have been thought to come from
we're very specialized in both the analytics
or very specialized in the systems area
but that's not going to do it in a real data
science problem and i hope i've illustrated that
you've got to be someone who can actually
do for instance not only the analytics but
the design component as well and your team has to
have that have those pieces on it if you want to
if the problem is so complex that you need
very very specialized people in analytics
then you've got to have equivalent nightmare
specialized people in design to help you
put this together so data science as we as we
think of practicing it now is very much this
interdisciplinary piece yeah i think this kind of
leads into the second part of that question which
was what sort of attributes are kind of necessary
for people who are interested in beginning careers
as data scientists oh wow um yeah this is this
is a fun question and i guess uh i could throw
it back to you as much as uh yeah but it's i
think i think a guy like you jack is a perfect
example i don't know since you were complimentary
in the beginning i think somebody who is uh who
is invested in a problem like you were invested
in the brain who's just really looking at it and
saying good gosh i want to understand these these
characteristics and i want to really understand
uh what's happening in this field uh and to
do that you're just naturally going to be led
to all four of those areas by you know by your
inquisitiveness about the fundamental question
that you're asking so i think somebody who comes
to data science has got to be someone who's
who's in inquisitive curious and wanting to really
make a difference in an area that is important uh
you know and and as a result they are going to
buy that very by that drive that they have toward
solving that be driven to these these four areas
that i've described and and wanting to understand
them so that they can really go after that problem
well that's great and um one final portion of this
before we get into some more technical questions
about things is uh you are the co-director of an
nih ctsa program and i'm curious what does
data science have to offer the biosciences
from the point of view of translational research
in terms of education and training oh in terms of
education training i was going to say if you if
you stopped before that i think it's everything
it offers everything to translation i think you
can't do translation without doing data science
i agree yeah but yeah uh i well in terms
of education we're trying to uh provide uh
you know i shouldn't say we're trying we have
provided a number of what we call learning shots
uh that are giving you you know more deep dives
and there in fact we have one that's specifically
on this four plus one model a colleague of mine
did and then i for instance did one on analytics
uh and so we give deep dives in each of these
areas we go we go in more depth to describe
characteristics of of each of these four areas and
so that's what we've been trying to do is to build
uh these learning shots out and
then we we have others that are just
again versions of my talk here today they're
they're case studies i gave you two quick overview
kind of case studies uh but we i have a colleague
for instance and she's built one that's on exactly
that environmental enteropathy she's done a full
up uh you know 30 or 40 minute presentation on
just that describing data science for that problem
instead of whatever i spent today five to ten
minutes i don't know what it was uh so yeah so
it's all of that together that's trying i think to
give people that are interested in translational
health science i've given them a sense of how data
science is so critical to their uh to their
mission that's great so uh some of the uh
questions that you're rolling in here you can take
a look at these yourself if you want to see the uh
uh some of the the language here but in
the discussion of the enteropathy was
kind of interesting you kind of mentioned uh
several techniques um for each of the outcomes
and how were you cho how are these chosen
um and based on predictive power for example
um and another part of this question that somebody
else is asking is uh how is the robustness defined
yeah um let me answer your first part and then
i'll try and deal with the second one um so the uh
the the first thing is that you know you bear in
mind this is like any talk that you uh that you
get you know i've never been to a a conference
where uh you know you don't get a talk where it
appears like uh you know they had this incredibly
complicated problem and boy they were brilliant
had these uh these uh these techniques and got
this great answer and gosh wasn't that wonderful
what you're missing is of course all the uh
the blood sweat and tears that went on to try
and figure all that out and how this went together
which you know you know and it was all there don't
get me wrong i'm not going to pretend uh we're
uh you know what can i say we're not uh jon snow
we didn't we didn't come up with these uh this
brilliant insight we there was a lot of work to
try different techniques out here jack you've got
a bit of more of that at that last thing that i
gave on the the surgical safety because i i put up
there the list of things that we were trying and
some of which didn't work very well at all and
that's really the way it was with environmental
and interrupting we tried a bunch of different
things and even to this day i mean this problem
we're still working on versions of these problems
right now and it's and we continually try stuff
uh and we're trying newer things we're trying
different versions of things the nice thing about
the world now is that as i say we've got a lot
of hardware and software that we can just spin
up and try quickly and throw it out when it
doesn't work uh so that's good uh the bad thing
is that we've got a lot of these things that we
can try so you've got a lot of things to choose
from so it can just frustrate the heck out of you
so you do have to be clever about how you're doing
it and you do have to take a a you know i'll say
a scientific approach and pick the ones that make
the most sense for your particular problem yeah
and somebody else was asking about uh a little
bit about the conditions that one might use to
kind of decide whether or not one should use a
say a traditional linear regression or a gradient
boosting style approach or maybe an alternative
might be uh whether or not you're going to use any
sort of uh penalized regression type of approach
you know what sort of things might you look at
in terms of the conditions of the data or is it
just you know you should try all these things
and find the one that works best no it's more
it's more than that because frankly it's kind
of what i said about this interpretability thing
the one that works best may not be uh best for
your your problem domain because i mean that
last one as i say it was extremely important
for us that the the surgeons in this case
understood uh what it was that they could use
in order to make these determinations because
it was important for them to know that since that
it isn't the matter of just plugging this in and
getting an answer out they want to basically
look at these characteristics of these patients
and themselves make a determination that's frankly
why they get paid the big bucks is they want they
they want they they need to make decisions about
their patients and they need to understand what it
is that this thing is giving them this thing being
the the data science uh solution that is telling
them hey this is a probability of this uh it's got
to give them that answer um i didn't answer the
question on robustness that i gave the robustness
thing i mentioned with regard to uh this uh color
balancing and that means that uh it's robust i can
give it uh different values i i you know different
ways in which we've done that color balancing and
it's still going to produce an answer that uh that
is that is good it's going to produce a very nice
answer so it's when i say that i mean it's it's uh
not sensitive it's it's not terribly sensitive
it's sensitive but it's not strongly sensitive
in the sense the results change dramatically for
the worse as a result of doing a different color
balancing and in general that's what we mean
and when we talk about robustness it's defined
formally in statistics and concerning you know
extreme values and that's pretty much where we're
how we're defining it here as well a little bit
more exacting with regard to this color balancing
stuff um and and okay gradient boosting over uh
traditional regression yeah the gradient boosting
over traditional regression the gradient boosting
is something that we can we can understand
uh and and look at the character look at the
features give the uh the surgeons again those
kind of things and gradient boosting has the
advantage that uh it's taking uh results from
extreme points it's taking these uh these unusual
points and it's learning from those and whereas
traditional regression doesn't do that it's just
a it's a batch approach and that and that's why
it turned out gradient boosting was was much more
effective in this because it could learn that way
so that's the reason that it was used well with
that i want to thank you don for giving us a
fantastic overview on data science as a discipline
as a collaborative space as a team sport
and some of the important uh elements that make
up modern data science uh and as it applies to
biomedicine i so thank you again and i want to
encourage all of you to uh join us once again
next friday at 12 noon eastern time and 9 00 a.m
pacific for our next in the series of biomedical
data science seminar series so thank you once
again everybody have a great weekend thank you bye